you telling me you want me through the
night the guys are back together and
they're hitting the road obviously it's
a nostalgia tour I'm sure we see a lot
of familiar faces from back in the day
what was that stuff some dance moves
Nick drew Justin and Jeff are headlining
the Mike's okay - oh what's the song
that you get requested the most from
fans I think probably the the I do has
been the psalm it's kind of stood the
test of time and it's been a lot of
people's wedding songs so I think that's
probably the one people said oh you know
I do mean you know meant so much to me
but I think you didn't know change yeah
is the one that people get most excited
about
now do the families crowd on tour with
you guys find a last tour we did well
paper it sounds like a great idea to
have your kids on the road with you yeah
then in practicality when you when you
get like in bed 2 a.m. after a long show
and meeting reads moving and then your
son wakes up at 6 and wants to be it's
like hmm whose idea was this
do the kids understand what their dads
jeez my daughter just turned 10 so she
gets it
but yeah the little ones they're just
like they like riding their scooters
around backstage and playing around on
the buses I sing around the house and my
son tells me to stop stop singing oh my
do you understand that people used to
pay that hopefully will